okay so I know everyone in the room is
very familiar with this area but these
talks are being recorded so let me just
start at the beginning so the 3-sum
problem is you're given a set of n
numbers and you want to know are there
are there a and B and C such that a plus
B equals C and it comes in lots of
different variants that aren't
substantively different you can say
maybe a B and C R have to be distinct
you can say maybe a B and C come from
their own sets capitals a B and C but
they're all essentially equivalent okay
so if you want to simulate being an
undergrad these days on the job circuit
you can try to come up with a an N
squared algorithm in like two minutes
which is what you're expected to do at
very good you know Bay Area companies i
think maybe five years ago it's probably
you know at a date by now but anyway it
is possible to come up with an N squared
algorithm with completely elementary
observations about the problem and the
job interviews usually don't distinguish
between a being a set of reals where you
manipulate it with comparisons and
additions and a being a set of integers
where you can manipulate it with other
natural operations on integers but the
problem does have to kind of natural
variants so the strong 3sum conjecture
from the from the 90s is that the the
job interview algorithm that you came up
with is optimal it's N squared time and
there's an you know even stronger
conjecture that the number of numerical
operations you need to solve the problem
is also n squared there's some
circumstantial evidence for for for this
in the 90s
ok so the strong 3sum conjecture is too
strong but it's might still be useful so
there's some weak refutations that say
that the strong 3sum conjecture is not
literally true but maybe spiritually
true so the it's not literally true
because you can beat n squared by a
smidge so beranda main and petrosky show
that you can beat it by a roughly log N
squared factor when the input is
integers this is randomized Fox last
year we showed you can do it we have end
of the three-halves comparisons a lot of
time but n to the three-halves
comparisons and you can shape about a
login factor off when there's when the
input is a reals okay so given that
there's week reputations the modern 3sum
conjecture i'll call it is that you
can't beat the exponent to you can beat
it by some lower order additive term
come sorry I didn't hear about the
drinking rule when I came in true story
so when my wife heard that I was working
on the threesome problem she told me in
so many words that this is a constant
time solvable problem because the answer
is always no so she didn't enter you
know didn't appreciate this but if
you're if you're open minded if you're
open to new experiences there's some
quadratic algorithms out there ok so
when de when la ceiba buys a big
announcement about graph isomorphism
came out people were always that guy
immediately afterward they said we
always knew this was going to be the
case because there was no hard
distribution it seems a little strange
the timing but they always said you know
what if you don't have a hard
distribution when you have come up with
a hard disk conjecture there's something
very suspect about it so as soon as you
give a hardness conjecture about a
problem you're probably obliged to
immediately come up with a hard
distribution and say beat this first and
then we can talk about the general
problem so here's the hard distribution
as far as we know for threesome pick a B
and C uniformly at random from the first
n squared integers and you're gonna have
three some witnesses all over the place
so then filter out every element of C
that's involved in a threesome witness
and whatever remains is your instance
and you can leave one witness and there
if you want it to be a positive instance
and if you don't like the filtering step
because that takes too much time to
actually generate something from this
distribution you can just pick a B and C
from the range 1 to N cubed and then
you'll have a constant number of
threesome witnesses and expectation and
and finding one as far as we know is
hard so if you want to look at a special
case of threesome look at randomized
instances
okay so here's a brief review of how
threesome was used in geometry mostly in
the 90s basically you have this is the
set of n numbers and you manipulate the
inputs with linear transformations and a
lot of times the reductions are almost
completely trivial like for let's say a
robot manipulation problem you could
create three infinite lines
corresponding to the sets a B and C put
little gaps in those lines break them up
corresponding to which numbers are in
the sets a B and C and say you have a
robot that's really really long and
really really really skinny say it's a
line and then you just show that the
only way you could possibly get the
robot from above the first line to below
the third line is if there was a
threesome witness in the original set
okay so reductions of this flavor we're
very common in the 90s okay so one thing
that I want to emphasize in this talk is
that the threesome conjecture is almost
it's at one end of the spectrum which is
what is the the largest running time
that we can you know state with a
straight face and a different way to
look at it is what is the weakest
threesome type conjecture that is still
useful so in this case the weakest
useful conjecture that you can come up
with is that threesome just takes
superlinear time this is the weakest
conjectural you can come up with it
gives you some kind of non-trivial
results because you had in input
complexity and you created some
geometric instance with complexity enzo
any super linear lower bound transfers
back to the original problem
okay so petrosky took a very short
departure from the the algebraic
reductions and to explain what petrosky
did I have to introduce a few more
problems because the 3-sum problem
wasn't perfectly suited to what he was
doing so 3some is given a set of n
numbers find a B and C such that a plus
B equals C convolution threesome is this
is not a good interview question find a
quadratic time algorithm for convolution
37 because it's it's obviously quadratic
so you're given an array of numbers and
you want to find indices I and J SEPs at
AI plus a J equals a I plus J okay so
he's going to reduce threesome the
convolution threesome and he's going to
reduce convolution threesome to set
destroying us so set destroyed mrs. were
given a set system a over a universe you
and some queries which are pairs of sets
and we want to know for each query pair
a B does set a intersect set B or not so
there's no obligation to find a witness
but it's just yes or no question
so set disjoint pneus is it's a sort of
a decision variant and the reporting
version of set destroyed this is the
input is identical but when you're given
the query you have to explicitly
enumerate in some arbitrary order the
elements in the intersection of a and B
okay so these are Petrovsky's reductions
so the first reduction is to get from
integer threesome two integer
convolution threesome and the basically
what he chose is that given any
parameter K there's some overhead of N
squared over K and then the reduction
makes roughly k cubed calls to a
convolution threesome algorithm so the
the right choice of K in this case
depends on the actual complexity of
convolution threesome and you have to
you know hypothesize what that would be
and then work backwards and pick the
optimum k so I petrosky didn't have this
in there but there's a minor error in in
his paper but you need a few more calls
to avoid witnesses of a certain type
that he didn't want okay so once you
have convolution threesome you can
reduce that to a set destroying this
instance so this set destroying this
instance has a universe of size n the
number of sets is end of the one half
plus epsilon epsilon is a parameter you
get to pick and cue the number of
queries is into the 1 plus epsilon same
parameter and regardless of what epsilon
you pick the input sizes n to the 1.5 so
the epsilon that you're allowed to pick
is not completely arbitrary so it
depends on the complexity of convolution
3some and if you know if everything is
quadratic the way we think it is epsilon
can be between one half and and one so
the point of this slide is to illustrate
a few weaknesses in petracic use
reduction the first is that you have no
control over the output size it's always
n to the 1.5 regardless of how you
choose any parameters so you can't
really create instances of arbitrary you
know types the second is that epsilon
has to be between one half and one so
which means that the number of queries
is n to the 1.5
five which means that the highest lower
bound that you can possibly expect for
query is square root of n squared a
little in okay and the third problem is
that there's there's a certain amount of
loss that it's introduced in all of
these reductions so you lose something
going from integer 3some to convolution
threesome and you lose a little bit more
going to set this joint yes and what I
talked about earlier the weakest useful
threesome hypothesis is actually not
really really strong so for example
you're bound on end of the epsilon here
you need you need a gap between this
lower bound and this upper bound for you
to be able to pick any end of the
epsilon at all and the only way that
this gap is a non-empty is if
convolution threesome is the exponent is
at least five thirds okay so then you
work back and you say well what happens
if we put a end of the five thirds up
here and then shows the optimum k and
figured out which running time for
threesome went that we would get we
would get 0 18 TTYL okay you work
backwards from there you'd say well if
the exponent for convolution threesome
is 5 thirds then the exponent for
threesome would be 13 / sevenths 13 / 7
and that's basically the threshold at
which you get any non-trivial results so
someone came along and you only have
these two reductions and someone give
you a end to the 13 / 7 threesome
algorithm everything could just
hypothetically unravel okay so
we're going to basically we're going to
use all the tools that Mihai use we're
going to use them in a different order
and assemble a reduction directly from
3some to set don't you set just
jointness and set intersection and get a
stronger results so we're going to get
higher lower bounds and we're also going
to get higher lower bounds from a weaker
threesome conjecture so where is here
the the weakest useful conjecture had
this exponent 13 / 7 we're going to get
this that weakest useful conjecture down
the end of the 1.5 okay so we have let's
say three input arrays a B and C to see
why this threesome just really really
naturally fits a set intersection set
destroying this framework you can say
suppose we're looking for all witnesses
involving some fixed element be in the
middle set this it can immediately be
rephrased as an intersection problem
where we take set a shift it all the
elements by B and ask does that
intersect C or not okay so three some if
you just write it the way right way
looks exactly like some kind of offline
set intersection thing except the sets
get shifted by these numerical values so
this is a wonderful trick from you hi if
you're if you're trying to simulate a
shifted set intersection it's useful to
look at these are integers so you can
just look at the bit representation of
the actual numbers a B and C and this is
equivalent to checking whether a shifted
by the high order bits of B is equal to
C shifted by the low order bits of be
okay so the number of ships here is
basically square root of the number of
possible shifts if you just look at the
a plus B equals C
okay so the algorithm is basically as
follows for each be we're going to check
if a shift it up by the high order bits
of B intersect C shifted down by the
lower order bits of B and if it is then
we know that we've found a threesome
witness and if it isn't then we move on
to the next be okay so this is a clearly
a set destroying this problem the number
of sets is 2 times the square root of
the universe I didn't say what the
universe was so it could be big so this
this can be really awful the total size
of all the sets is is n times square
root of the universe which is way way
too big you know if you're looking for
an N squared running time you doesn't
have to be that big before this is
already exceeding your budget and the
number of destroying as queries is is N
1 for each element in B so the way we're
going to fix this is use hashing so the
universe is too big and n is too big so
we're gonna use hashing to basically fix
both of those problems make the universe
smaller and make set sizes smaller
okay so mean hashing for low value so
this is a this was introduced in borunda
men in petrosky so we'll call a
distribution over hash functions HC
universal if the probability of getting
a collision between H of X and H of Y is
C times what it should be so the range
of the function is our and it should be
one of our our but it might be as much
as C times 1 over R okay so suppose we
take a SE universal hash function and we
have a set of elements a and we hash a
into buckets as follows bucket I is
everything with hash value I ok so we
expect to see an over are elements in a
bucket and if it has three end of our
elements will call it over full and over
folds definitely bad so think this is a
bad event and the theorem from bar on
demand and petrosky oh is that if if H
is one universal that is it is exactly
as good as a random function in terms of
mounting the probability of collisions
then the expected number of elements in
over full buckets is on the order of the
number of buckets this is weaker than
what you'd expect via total randomness
you know via jaron Chernoff bounds for
example but it's still very strong ok
and I want to illustrate exactly why
it's strong by showing that this this
one universality thing right here is
actually really critical to the proof
and that the whole thing unravels if you
don't have one universality
okay so and the claim is that this isn't
true if you allow any deviation
whatsoever from one universality so
here's the counter example we'll pick a
hash function H from the following
distribution H of a is with epsilon
probability mapped to an epsilon over
for fraction of the range and with 1
minus epsilon probability it's mapped to
the rest of the range uniformly at
random so pictorially we're just taking
an epsilon fraction of the universe and
compressing it down to epsilon number
four in the range and taking the rest
and compressing it down to the the rest
of the range expanding it out into the
rest of range okay so it's fairly easy
to verify two things this doesn't screw
up the collision probability that much
it's still one plus something on the
order of epsilon Universal and because
that the expected bucket size for the
buckets in this part of the range is
four times what you would expect nearly
everything in this in these buckets is
going to be at over full buckets so an
epsilon fraction of the elements in the
set get map down to something where they
are almost certainly going to be in over
full buckets okay so epsilon an and are
unrelated parameters there's no way to
bound one in terms of the other so that
this theorem basically falls apart
unless you have strict one universality
okay so hashing for universe reduction
hashing for load balancing is going to
this is one use of hashing hashing for
universe reduction we're going to need a
little bit slightly different properties
because when generally when you think of
hashing something you think you're just
screwing up the data right so we're
looking for threesome witnesses if you
have the input data you're going to
screw up the data and destroy the
property of being a threesome witness so
what we need now is hash functions that
in addition to having nice properties
like one universality are also linear so
they preserve threesome witnesses so
we'll call each linear if H of X plus h
of y equals H of X plus y for any X Y
and linear is linear functions are too
hard to come by so we'll settle for this
definition of almost linear so we'll say
H is almost linear if you have linearity
and you may be off by linearity by a
term that depends on the hash function
you chose but not the inputs and you may
be off by that by some additive amount
so the whole point of this is that is
that H of X plus h of y is one of a
constant number of possible values
depending on H of X plus y ok so here's
a first try this this hash function was
suggested in Iran deport Roscoe and
later in petrosky because it's it seems
to fit all the the bills it's clearly
almost linear so what is this what does
this function actually I doing if you
write this out in C notation maybe it
looks a little bit more easy to digest
but you pick a random odd integer a you
multiply that by the thing you're
hashing and that creates a two-word you
know output mod 2 to the ww is the word
sighs this retains the lower order word
and then you shift out all but the are
higher order bits of the lower order
word okay and that's your hash value so
except for this part right here it's
linear and all you're doing here is
throwing away lower order bits so you
get almost linear where C is zero and
zero and one here just is there because
when you throw away lower order bits and
you add two numbers you might be losing
a carry and that's what this this one is
is the law scary okay to first try
because it doesn't it doesn't work so
this this function is not one universal
its to Universal and therefore you can't
apply the load balancing lemma given
this function maybe you can but you have
to prove it you know on an ad hoc basis
you can't say because it's to Universal
it's good enough to Universal ality is
not in and of itself good enough
okay so the second try is not that much
different so instead of saying ax you
just say ax plus B a and B your random
random w bit words so the be here is
basically going to affect the choice of
ch
okay so these will be our 90 show that
this if this is pairwise independents
not just one universal but it's pairwise
independent and it's also one universal
because of that and we're going to use
both of these properties one
universality for the load balancing
lemma and pairwise independence for
other things so when I say a half
function I mean one from this class
where a and B are drawing uniformly at
random okay so remember the setup we
have a fixed be in the be set and we're
looking for an a and the a set and see
you in the cset they form a threesome
witness and we want to reduce this to
some kind of set destroyed and square so
the first thing that we do is we pick a
hash function H and we hash sets a and C
into our buckets are is we get to choose
our and we hash them into our buckets
using the the bucketing described before
okay so assuming none of these buckets
are over full we don't care about that
for this talk okay so and then also
assume that H is completely linear
because all the stuff about
approximately arity is just noise it
doesn't interfere with you know what's
actually going on so assume that H is
perfectly linear H of a plus h b is
always exactly h of a plus B so if a B
and C formed a threesome witness then
their hash values also form a threesome
witness so we'll call the bucket that a
got hashed into a bucket I and the
bucket that C got hashed into bucket J
so to solve threesome we just have a
quick you know set of nested loops here
so for every possible value of B we pick
every possible value of the bucket that
a could have been hashed into hey I so
once you fix be you get a chubby once
you fix i J is a function of those two
so you immediately get j and now you can
reduce the question is there a threesome
witness involving be to the set
intersection query for each I does a I
shifted by B intersect CJ and if it does
then you found a threesome witness and
if it doesn't then there is no threesome
witness involving be
okay so here we have here we have a type
of intersection query that we'd like to
to to support so here's the the
observation for why this is it going to
be efficient so AI is a bucket CJ is a
bucket and let's say they're not over
full so they each have something on the
order of n over R elements in them okay
so with the birthday non paradox in mind
we'll pick a new almost linear hash
function H prime it has to be I mean you
know independent of H that we picked
before to do the actual bucketing click
a new function H prime that map's
whatever the universe is down to the
size of these buckets squared okay so
this is roughly equivalent to asking a
question under the projection of H prime
does a I does that bucket a I shifted by
B intersect the bucket CJ okay now
because I mean this is not is almost
equivalent right because you could get a
something that looks like a threesome
witness here I mean if you see an
intersection under these two sets it
doesn't necessarily translate into a
into a witness in the original problem
okay and then of course we can apply the
same trick by moving the higher order
bits of H crime of be in the lower two
bits of h prime of B into into a
separate offsets on these on these sets
so remember that the Hydra bits and low
order bits is the number of different
ships here is square root of the
universe but the universe is not you
anymore it's the size of these buckets
squared so the number of shifts that
we're talking about handling is only n
over R
okay so if there was no threesome
witness involving be in these two sets
ate an AI and CJ then these sets started
off as disjoint and under this this
pairwise independent function H Prime
they stay disjoint with constant
probability because of this birthday non
paradox so if we want to have a higher
confidence when the answer is when the
answer is guess here that there is a
witness and we want to have higher
confidence that this this answer is a
this correct will just repeat this test
log in independent times with different
h prime values and if all log n of them
say yes there's an intersection here
then we actually go and look for an
intersection and we had to find a false
positive with negligible probability or
we find an actual three some witnessin
halt okay so roughly speaking this is
what we've done we've created a set
destroying this it instance from the
threesome instance where there's an
login sets regardless of what number of
buckets we use so we have our buckets
and where our shifts and log in
different hash functions there's so 10
log n independent of our the total size
of all sets is roughly n squared over R
and the total number of queries is
roughly n times R so the number of
queries was we had to check every value
of B and we had to check every value of
where a got you know which bucket a got
hashed into and that's the each of those
corresponds to a separate set destroying
this instance said just witness query
okay so in this reduction so in in me
heís a reduction epsilon was bounded
between one half and one and in this
reduction let's call the size of the
number of buckets end of the game again
was unrestrained so a gamma can be
anywhere between zero and one and we
don't get run into any trouble
okay so if you believe the 3some the the
threesome conjecture that you need n
squared time to solve the threesome
instance that says that figuring out
answering these n are destroying this
queries also must take little n squared
time okay and if you run through this
reduction with a different hypothesis
you'll see that nothing you still get
non-trivial results if the complexity of
threesome is in to some exponent that's
strictly greater than 1.5 and at one
point five basically everything just
vanishes and you get nothing okay so
here are some interesting implications
for for online set destroy us so that we
reduce it to offline set destroying this
one way you can solve offline at
destroying this is with an online set
destroying this algorithm that pre
processes the sets in advance and then
online answers queries so it doesn't
know the queries in advance so we're
just getting to a heart a problem but
this is this is useful because a these
data structures you know exist this
basically you know any search engine the
answers to query word searches is is
doing exactly this so it's you know well
motivated but it also lets us
disentangle pre-processing costs from
query costs and and see what the
reductions are actually showing so we
have you know two to them- end of the
two- guiana size of all of our sets and
roughly n to the 1 plus gamma query so
that's kind of the this is what gamma
controls here so here's some interesting
implications so if you send gamma close
to zero not equal zero but just close to
zero and you want a data structure that
has near linear time pre-processing this
lower bound says that you need a square
root of n time query time per set /
destroying this query if you send gamma
close to one and you demand near
constant query time then you need near
quadratic pre-processing time okay so if
you go through me highs reactions and
look
the same you know points on the
trade-off curve if you needed near
linear time pre-processing in his
reduction you would get n to the
one-third lower bound for query and if
you needed near constant query times
you'd get n to the four thirds lower
bound for preprocessing ok so this
second the second one right here which i
think is pretty relevant is if you want
constant query time you need quadratic
reprocessing time this is basically
tight getting quadratic pre-processing
I'm in constant query time just doing
the dumb brute force thing is is
basically an optimal algorithm you're
not going to you're not going to improve
this exponent here to buy by any and all
and the first trade-off here is not
really tight but you know it's getting
there so the best data structures if you
want square root of n query time you
need about n to the 1.5 pre-processing
time instead of your linear time but
that's basically the state of affairs
right now
so there are some limitations to this
reduction from threesome to set destroy
nests so one reason set destroying this
is a really useful problem is because so
many other problems particularly graph
problems can be expressed as set
destroying us you can you know these
reductions are so easy they're almost
not you know worth enumerate anymore so
but one of the problems is that when you
when you take a set destroying this
instance and represented as a graph
roughly speaking the the size of the
sets gets translated into a number of
edges and the number of vertices is you
get a constant number of vertices per
set and / universe element so you pay
for the sets and the universe elements
in vertices and in here we had n log n
vertices representing sets and we'll
have something like end of the 2-2 gamma
vertices representing the universe so if
you get gamma to be not too big then
this is a lot of vertices so the densest
graphs you could possibly create using
this type of reduction as you pick gamma
equals one half and you get roughly n
log n vertices an end to the three
halves edges and you can't create a
dense or graph using this reduction so
this is this is sort of disappointing
but I feel like this is sort of an
intrinsic barrier with this line of
thinking because if you ask a set
destroying this query you need the
answer to be informative you need you
know zero a non intersecting set to
being one thing and an intersecting set
to mean something else so if you're
creating basically instances generated
at random the universe size in ours is
always the average set size squared and
if you try to make the universe smaller
you're not going to get anything
informative out of these set
intersection queries because they're
always going to intersect there's
nothing going to be in and there's going
to be no information coming out of these
set intersection queries so this is sort
of an intrinsic barrier and the way we
get rounded is just switching the
problem we don't really you know fix
this directly so here is a way around it
we change the problem so instead of the
data structure the set destroyed in this
data structure just saying yes or no
things intersect or don't we're going to
look at a slightly different problem set
intersection and it's just like set
destroying us remember but where the
you're obliged to enumerate everything
in the intersection so the reduction is
exactly the same we still use H to hash
into buckets and now we choose H prime
to be instead of the average number of
things in a bucket squared is the new
universe we pick it to be the average
number of things in a bucket times into
the Delta where Delta is a new parameter
so if you make Delta a you know kind of
smallish then you're going to create
instances where sets intersect by a lot
and all the the points in the
intersection are going to be informative
so now the reduction says when you have
to answer it aside intersection query
let's say it's a hash shifted by some
high order bits be etcetera etc report
everything in this intersection and
every element in this intersection is
going to correspond to a false positive
which you can quickly check and throw
away or an actual threesome witness and
you have to go through everything in the
intersection to figure out which ones
which okay so the expected so total size
of the output of all of these
intersection queries is going to be n to
the two minus Delta which just says that
you need about end of the Delta time /
reporting operation if without violating
the threesome conjecture
okay and if you look at how this
reduction works you can create very very
dense instances by making Delta very
close to zero but not equal zero and
gamma very close to one-third so in this
type of parameterization what you do is
you basically create a graph with
roughly end of the two-thirds vertices
and end to the Four Thirds edges and
it's nearly complete and with different
parameters ations you can create graphs
of almost any density okay so let me
just give sort of one point on this
queer a trade-off curve for for set
intersection and see what kind of
implications this lower bound has so
suppose we have a set intersection data
structure so it actually reports the
intersection of two sets and we have pre
processing time TP query time TQ so when
we ask a query it's going to take TQ
time regardless of what the set
intersection looks like and for each
element in the output were allowed TR
times so TR is the reporting time so we
have some data structure and its running
time is characterized by these three
things then we have this lower bound
this is very ugly-looking because we
have two independent levers that were
that we're controlling we have the gamma
lever and the delta lever they both
control different things so this is not
really an easy trade up to get a handle
on except by fiddling with it so you can
just you know pick some random things so
let's say hypothetically we have a data
structure whose pre-processing time is
less than into the Four Thirds who's
reporting time is near constant what
this thing what this lower bound implies
if you send gamma and Delta close to
zero is that you need at least end of
the two-thirds query time even though
the output of the set intersection
queries is less than n to the two-thirds
okay and this is actually one point
Donna on a tight trade-off curve so
there is a data structure you know with
a trade-off curve that actually meets
this particular point in lots of other
points
okay so I'll show one more reduction of
how you get from set destroying pneus to
a graph problem which will maybe be a
good segue into these talk so a lot of
the other implications that we get from
from from this is new new bounds on the
complexity of reporting triangles and
sees going to talk about that but I just
want to talk about another thing dynamic
maximum matching so here the problem is
you maintain some dynamic graph and you
get to add vertices and edges and the
incremental operations and delete
vertices and edges and those are the
detrimental operations so it's pretty
easy to show that if you literally have
to maintain a memory an explicit
representation of a maximum matching
that you can't do this in less than
linear time so we're going to weaken
this lightly and just say after each
operation we just want to know the size
of a maximum matching which there's no
obvious bottleneck for this type of
query okay so abuddin Williams gave
lower bounds in this problem via some
some stepping stones from other problems
and I think you can express their lower
bound in terms of the number of edges or
the number of vertices but for reasons
it'll be clear later on I'm going to
express their lower bound in terms the
number of vertices so they show that if
your data structure is amortized and
fully dynamic you need square root of n
sort of in time / you know number of
vertices sort of number of vertices / /
operations and if your data structure
has worst-case guarantees but it's only
incremental you get the same lower bound
it's the same reduction but there's two
ways to kind of you know phrase that in
terms of amortized fully dynamic in
worst-case incremental and it doesn't
really seem possible to kind of combine
the best of both worlds in these
reductions and end up with just one half
exponent so here I just want to show a
cute little technique for getting some
kind of non-trivial exponent here in the
amortized incremental universe
so it so this is the basic setup there's
gonna be three blocks blobs represent
the following things so remember trying
to simulate with a matching instance the
set intersection queries where we look
at a setting arrived from a intersect
asset derived from C and see if they're
empty or not so these blobs will contain
vertices that represent sets drive from
a this blob will you know have things
derived from C and this blob here will
be things derived from the universe so
for each universe element you will
create two vertices and an edge between
them for each set derived from a will
create two sets to two vertices a and a
prime with an edge between them and if
you is in a prime then we'll connect
these two vertices by an edge and we'll
do something symmetric for the seaside
for each set little see okay two
vertices C and C prime connect a seed to
you see if if the element you is in the
set C okay so if you if you stare at
this graph you'll see that it has a
unique perfect matching you just match
every vertex with its partner and that's
the only perfect matching so it looks
like this so if you want to intercept
destroying this query you just come
along and add a new edge from a new
vertex X to a prime a new edge from a
new vertex y to z prime and if the size
of the maximum matching rows after you
add these two edges then you know that
sets a and C intersect you have to stare
at it for a little then then you believe
it so you know if the intersect you have
a very short augmenting path and if they
don't intersect it's not like there's
some long contrived venting path there
is no augmenting path if they don't
intersect okay so that's basically how
you answer exactly one set destroying
this query and now what you have to do
is delete these edges that you just
inserted so you can move on and ask the
second set destroying this query and the
third and so forth so you need a way to
do deletions so if you're in the
amortized incremental model there is no
deletion operation so you don't really
have a direct way to delete these edges
okay so there's two ways that you can
functionally undelete delete edges in
this problem and we'll use both of them
so to functionally delete these edges
what you could do is just basically
every time that these adage and advert
ex operations are doing their thing you
just record all the memory addresses
that they look at and the values that
were there before and when you're done
adding the edges from x and y you just
roll back the data structure to the
state it was in before they were there
and then you can start from there and
then do the next one so if you have
worst-case guarantees a rollback you
know how much a rollback cost because
there was a worst-case guarantee and you
could roll back the operations in
worst-case time but if you have an
amortized guarantee rollbacks don't work
you could have a very expensive
operation and rolling it back it's not a
good idea okay so that's a general way
to get basically do deletes a specific
way to do deletes that's only relevant
to the matching problem as far as I can
tell is you can simulate deletes by
adding more vertices more edges if you
just add another vertex y prime and
connected Y and X and X prime then you
again arrive at a graph where it has
unique perfect matching where every
vertex is matched with its with its
partner okay and you functionally
deleted those two edges so basically
figuring out exactly what the sex point
own is is kind of tedious but basically
you divide the operations that the set
destroy meanest queries into cheap and
expensive if it's cheap meaning it came
in under it's amortized budget then you
undo the the inserts with memory
rollback and if it's expensive then you
undo the inserts with more inserts and
you grow the number of vertices so when
you grow the number of vertices you
change the threshold for what cheap and
expensive is and figuring out exactly
how big this graph can get is a kind of
tedious because the graph starts out
with you inserted so many edges and
vertices at the beginning it starts out
with this possibly enormous reservoir of
potential that it can spin down in the
future with amortized operations so this
vast reservoir of potential at the
beginning
is basically going to influence how many
vertices end up in the graph eventually
which ba-ba-ba-ba so this exponent is
like square root of 17 minus 1 over 8 so
how much shorter I'm fine just time
exists two minutes okay so here's an
open problem I'm curious to know the the
exact relationship you're doing
convolution threesome threesome so
they're either there you know me hives
redirecting show they are both similarly
sub quadratic meaning they're both off
by log factors or off by polynomial
factors or off by at something in
between but that's the highest level of
granularity you can you can really say
so it's easy to show convolution
threesome is reducible to three sub F
seizing a new result we have is that
threesome is reducible to log in
instances of convolution threesome of
the same size so the gap here is no more
than log N and this is this is
randomized endings is hatching its etc
so it's only four four four integers so
getting rid of the log n is something
and also just identifying any type of
relationship between 3some and
convolution threesome over the reals so
this is an issue that actually shows up
in a lot of reductions which is that
when you're hopping between problems
sometimes you need the the reductions
between problems actually depend on some
bounded precision in the integer inputs
because you're doing some kind of search
over energy inputs okay so I have no
idea whether threesome and convolution
threesome are related over the reals
okay there's another interesting of one
problem so Williamson William to show
the convolution threesome even the real
version of it is reducible to square
root of n instances of zero of the zero
weight triangle problem on square root
of n nodes and this has very interesting
implication says that you know either
one of these two things is rather you
know why does cubic and the others
quadratic or or they're both going to be
sub Q biquette some quadratic and
separately integer is a PSP is also
usable 20 a triangle okay and so this
reduction just fiddles with the numbers
in some completely linear way okay and
it works with reals doesn't matter this
reduction is actually looking at the bit
representation of the weights so this is
a this is not the reduction is not quite
the same flavor as this but it's very
similar okay so the fact that this 0oi
triangle no problem exists and is
related to these other two things says
that there's some moral connection
between these two and we were nice if
you could have a really explicit
tangible connection between convolution
threesome and a PSP okay le couldn't be
here but uh he's busy
yes somewhere in your top you mentioned
that there was a reduction from mum I
think it was three some to graph
problems yeah it was unfortunate that
the number of edges is at most n to the
three house yeah well for example a lot
of problems have this phenomenon where
you you you cmn running times that are
you know as far as we know optimal up
into a certain density and then suddenly
a fast matrix multiplication becomes a
realistic technique and then you see a
completely different spectrum of running
times after some density so the fact
that we can only create some graphs of
some densities means that when we say an
algorithm is optimal we mean Oh only for
sparse instances and what we wanted to
do is say something really strong and
say you know both the algebraic
algorithms for dense instances and the
combinatorial ones for sparse instances
are optimal and that's why we needed to
create dense ones is is to think about
you know basically lower bounds for a
bit algorithmic techniques that only
kick in at certain densities oh it's up
yeah it's a nice range a butt right yeah
I'm not saying that dense graphs show up
in nature a lot but you know I don't
think they do
cute kid huh